initiated by president trump
was a negotiation to determine who would
be in power
what areas they would hold and when the
united states would leave
it was president trump who initiated
that negotiation
not president biden president biden when
he took office
followed through with it i applauded him
for doing so
i realize i think everyone does the
situation in afghanistan is perilous
but i think that we ought to acknowledge
the obvious
after the longest war in the history of
the united states
after losing over a thousand american
lives
and tens of thousands wounded after
spending trillions of dollars
we were not winning in afghanistan we
didn't have a winning hand or a winning
strategy
the taliban was still a viable political
force
and the afghan security forces many
times
are overwhelmed by that taliban force
i wonder why the republican leader from
kentucky
doesn't do the obvious he has the
authority
under the rules of the senate to
introduce a measure
calling authorizing the use of military
force in afghanistan
if he believes we should stay or send
more troops there that is his right
he can offer that on the floor of the
senate instead of lamenting what has
happened there
he has the authority if he thinks we've
abandoned the afghan
people and should go back into that
country
why doesn't he offer that an
authorization of use of military force
i think we know the answer there's
little or no support on his side of the
aisle
nor on this side of the aisle to make
the longest war
in american history even longer yes we
should be a viable force to try to make
certain the afghan people
have a fighting chance but after almost
20 years at it
i think we have shown that our strategy
was not the winning strategy
madam president on a different subject
as our nations continue to emerge from
covet 19
restrictions vaccinated americans are
able to gather
safely this past weekend for two happy
events
father's day and the first juneteenth
federal holiday
these celebrations came at the end of a
week that brought
welcome news to america after years
11 years of fighting the affordable care
act
the supreme court finally said to the
republicans enough
millions of americans have health
insurance at a time when they
desperately need it in the midst of a
pandemic
and your theories on constitution and
law
are not adequate to end the affordable
care act
thank goodness for that ruling seven to
two ruling
the administration of course was
heartened by that
and by the knowledge that we are fast
approaching the point where
70 of the adults in america are going to
be vaccinated
remember when president biden took
office six months ago
yes we had the vaccines but we hadn't
produced them in quantity
and we didn't have a plan for
vaccinating america
thank goodness now the united states is
leading the world
in the effort to vaccine vaccinate its
population
i thank president biden for that and the
resources
that we've provided to him we still have
a challenge
we still have a threat the delta variant
is much more easily spread
and covers strain that shut down the
nation last year
it has now been identified in 41 states
for those who are holding back and not
get seeking a vaccination
they are in greater danger than they
were a year ago
if that infection comes near them i hope
my
republican colleagues will join the
democrats emerging
american be vaccinated as quickly as
possible
on a different topic madam president
last week marked
50-year anniversary of president nixon's
declaration of a war
on drugs today america
imprisons a greater share of its
population
than any nation on earth drugs are
cheaper and more
easily available than ever and substance
abuse is destroying more american
families than ever
the greatest harm has fallen on our most
vulnerable citizens
particularly low-income americans and
communities of color
during the first four decades of the
nixon war on drugs
america's federal prison population grew
by
700 percent and the cost of operating
federal prisons
exploded by 1 100
today nearly half the people in federal
prison
are locked up due to drug related
charges
we are learning the hard way we can't
jail our way out of a public health
crisis
in recent years the senate's come
together
on a significant bipartisan basis direct
to correct some of the gravest mistakes
of the war on drugs
i'm grateful to my friend the ranking
republican member on the judiciary
committee
senator chuck grassley for his
leadership in this effort
we have been a partnership bipartisan
partnership
that ended up sending the first step act
a reform movement
to president bush to sign into law
pardon me said president trump
to sign into law tomorrow the senate
judiciary committee will hold a hearing
on another crucial piece of reform
eliminating the disparate treatment of
crack and potter cocaine
under federal sentencing laws congress
established this
unjust sentencing disparity at the
height of the crack epidemic in the
1980s
based on fear and mistaken
allusions to science we reduced the
disparity with the fair sentencing act
but we didn't eliminate it today a
person arrested
for 28 grams of crack will receive the
same sentence
as a person with 500 grams of cocaine
powder
even though it's exactly the same drug
this lingering disparity made racial
inequities in our criminal justice
system
even worse undermine faith
in the integrity of our justice system
and worst of all
failed to even curb drug addiction in
america
talk about three strikes we should
eliminate
the disparity once and for all and
there'll be a hearing tomorrow
on another matter madam president
tomorrow our democracy will face one of
its greatest tests in the senate
on january 7th at the close of
at close to four o'clock in the morning
this senate voted to confirm the
electoral victory
of joe biden to be the next president of
the united states
but we all know what happened before
that vote an angry
self-pitying man who would not accept
defeat
we now know scheme for weeks about how
to overturn the election and to continue
his presidency
when donald trump's efforts failed and
democracy prevailed
he begged a mob to come to washington
and deliver him from reality
you've seen the videos and films the
president standing with the white house
in the background railing this crowd
about an election that was stolen
urging them to come to capitol hill and
make a difference
he demanded that they come and stop the
steel and then he turned that mob on the
capital of the united states
those of us who were here that day will
never forget it
the outrageous insurrection that
followed was the worst attack on this
building
and the most prolonged siege of the
capital since the british attacked our
capital
in the war of 1812. five people died
more than 140 police officers were
injured
it could have been worse senator lindsey
graham
republican south carolina was right when
he said the day after the attack quote
that mob could have been could have
killed us all
the assault on the capital left our
nation shaken
and the world in disbelief that it could
happen in america
but it is not was not what one group of
one
pardon me but it was not what had one
group of washington power peddlers
worried the most
these washington insiders scheduled a
private conference call
just a few days two days after this
attack on the capitol
they were scrambling to come up with a
plan to kill
a democracy reform bill the call was
organized by the koch brothers
organization
among the participants was senator
mcconnell a recording of the call found
its way to jane mayer an investigative
reporter for the new yorker magazine
who wrote about it according to mrs miss
mayor's reporting the reason the
political insiders
and special interest in that call were
frightened was because they couldn't
find a way to beat
s-1 the koch brothers group had pole
tested
every attack they could think of against
the bill and none of it worked
it wasn't just democrats who liked the
reforms in that bill
it turned out the republicans liked them
too according to a coke representative
who hosted the meeting quote
there's a large very large chunk of
conservatives
who are supportive of these types of
reforms surprise surprise
what's a poor political insider to do
when you can't manufacture a reason to
vote against a bill
there's only one way to stop it and what
they referred to was
under the dome strategies to stop this
electoral reform bill
you know what that is that's the
filibuster
the kill buster that senate procedure
which requires 60 votes
they knew they couldn't win a majority
but they knew that it was tough to come
up with 60
votes in favor and that's what i'm
afraid we're going to see tomorrow
i hope not
last night i watched with many americans
as the movie selma
was televised
it reminded us of what happened in the
1960s
when people like my personal friend and
a hero to many of us
john lewis marched across that bridge in
selma alabama
trying to speak up for what voting
rights for african americans
he was beaten and bloodied and almost
died in the process
but they mustered the strength to come
back again and to resume the march
and they prevailed in passing a voting
rights act
that gave a fighting chance for african
americans and other people
to be able to vote in the future of
america
this still is a challenge to us today
why i don't know we've seen
in the recent past six or seven
republicans publicly break
with donald trump in some of his more
outrageous positions
and yet they have been strangely silent
on that side of the aisle
when it comes to what is happening at
states across the nation
where we have measures taking place
that will limit the right of people to
vote
what's wrong with this picture is
democracy not at its strongest point
when more people
are participating and yet republican
legislatures write bill after bill
to limit those who may be able to vote
in the future
i want to say a word to about my
colleague senator joe manchin
i want to thank him for his determined
efforts to find a compromise
on the bill that's coming before us
senator manchin spoke to
everyone in sight republicans democrats
independents
liberals conservatives and he listened
the compromise he proposed is not
inclusive of everything i'd like to see
in the bill
but the reality is that it would be an
improvement
it would help address the dangerous
all-out assault on voting rights that's
taking place in all these states that i
mentioned
it could help put jim crow back in the
grave where he belongs
and it deserves the support of the
senate
my last word before i close
i had the honor of serving with senator
robert byrd
he used to sit back here and i remember
standing in front of his desk as a new
united states senator and he told me
in his illustrious senate career the
things he was
embarrassed by the most he talked about
deregulation of airlines which took the
planes out of his state of west virginia
he talked about a nominee for the
eisenhower cabinet
who was rejected because he was jewish
he told me he was wrong in the way he
voted on those measures
but he said mr durbin more than anything
i was wrong on civil rights
madam president this past saturday was
not only juneteenth
it was the 57th anniversary of the
senate's passage of the civil rights act
of 1964. it had been filibustered for
two months
before it passed opposition to the bill
wasn't divided along party lines but
i'll be very honest
my party the democratic party
particularly southern members of the
party
were leading the fight against it on
june 8
1964 one of the most conservative
democrats
stood on the floor with an 800-page
speech
filled with all kinds of reasoning about
why civil rights
was unnecessary and an infringement on
states rights an
echo of a speech we just heard on the
senate floor
that senator's name was robert c byrd he
spoke on this floor for 14 hours and 13
minutes
when he finished the majority leader
called the roll and 71 senators voted to
end the filibuster
four more than was needed ten days later
on juneteenth 1964 the senate passed the
civil rights act
on july 2nd passed the house was signed
by president johnson
robert seabird would go on to serve for
another 46 years in the senate
become majority leader twice and the
longest serving senator in history
he later called his filibuster of the
civil rights act quote
the worst mistake of my life a decision
which he told me personally he deeply
regretted
he would change he would begin to
champion civil rights
when president george w bush signed the
law extending voting rights in 2006
it was robert c byrd by his side in the
oval office
along with ted kennedy and john lewis
when robert byrd died in 2010 john lewis
mourned him
and called him an ally and true
statesman
yet despite all the years that had
passed and all the good he accomplished
prominent many articles about his death
was the fact that he once stood against
civil rights
none of us knows knows how long we have
to serve in the senate
or even on this earth if the last year
has taught us anything
life is fragile so i implore my
colleagues who may be wrestling
with how to vote tomorrow this is a vote
for history
this is democracy on trial think about
how you want to be remembered
by your children's children if democracy
is worth fighting for
even worth dying for surely a democracy
reform bill
is worthy of debate in the senate allow
the senate to do its job
and debate before the people act i yield
the floor
clerk will call the world ms baldwin
senator from new hampshire madam
president i ask that the quorum call be
lifted
without objection thank you i come to
the floor today to join
my colleague senator collins from maine
who will be here shortly
who is also the my
co-chair of the diabetes caucus to
reintroduce the improving medicare
beneficiary access to innovative
diabetes technologies act
this is legislation that would establish
a task force to provide
recommendations to help guide medicare's
decisions on coverage and payment
for new technologies to improve the
lives of people with diabetes
now i have had the opportunity to see
the challenges that families with
members who have type 1 diabetes face
my granddaughter my oldest granddaughter
has type one
and i know the challenges that her
family faces navigating a complex web of
insurance coverage rules
um for technologies
a new technology comes out that would
benefit her
to get the insurance companies to adopt
those technologies
is a huge challenge and it requires
hours of phone time with the insurance
company
trying to persuade them that they should
provide the coverage
well we know that these insurance
companies
often base their coverage and
reimbursement rules on medicare
and that's why it's so important for the
medicare program to keep
pace with the development of new
diabetes technologies and devices
i appreciate the opportunity to work
with senator collins
on a regular basis in the diabetes
caucus
and in 2017 we were successful in
pressing
medicare to cover continuous glucose
monitors
something that seems like an obvious
choice given the difference that those
cgms can make
for people who have diabetes in ensuring
that their blood sugar stays
stable we've also worked together to
ensure that medicare provides
flexibility
so that patients can use smart phone
apps with their continuous glucose
monitors
and in the years to come we need
medicare to make
progress toward covering the artificial
pancreas
a landmark development that will be the
most significant change for people with
diabetes
since insulin was discovered
but to do this we shouldn't have to
resign ourselves
to this piecemeal approach to medicare
coverage
that requires continual pressure from
congress and advocates
we need an independent body like the one
that's
identified in our legislation to help
provide
recommendations to medicare so that its
coverage of new technologies can adapt
more quickly as innovation advances
that's why i'm proud
to be here on the floor and proud to
join senator collins in reintroducing
this bill
i hope that my colleagues will take a
look at it
decide that it merits passage and work
with us to get that done
so my colleague has arrived on the floor
senator collins i was just saying that i
was very proud to be able to join you in
reintroducing this legislation and
hopefully
this session we will be able to get it
done
um so thank you for your leadership and
i look forward to hearing
your comments and to working to get this
passed
madam president senator from maine
thank you president first let me thank
my colleague from new hampshire senator
shaheen
for her extraordinary commitment and
leadership
as my fellow co-chair of the senate
diabetes
caucus we are introducing a bill
to improve access to
innovative diabetes technologies for our
seniors
and other medicare beneficiaries
our bill would create a special task
force
at the department of health and human
services
to examine and resolve barriers that
seniors face
in accessing the latest diabetes
technologies new diabetes
technologies such as the artificial
pancreas and
implantable continuous glucose
monitoring systems allow
those who are living with diabetes to
better manage
their glycemic glycemic levels
assess needed therapy on a timely basis
and adhere better to treatment regimes
these technological advances make
diabetes
easier to manage and therefore improve
the health
of people with diabetes the market
arrival
of cutting edge diabetes technologies is
something
that we all celebrate however
oftentimes we're finding that patients
do not realize the full benefits
because many far nation seniors find the
new
technologies to be difficult or
impossible for them
to afford i have heard from
numerous seniors who when transitioning
from
employer-provided insurance to medicare
were shocked to learn that the
technologies that they'd relied upon
for years to manage their diabetes
are no longer covered because they now
have lost their employer provided
insurance which
did cover these technologies
and instead are being covered by
medicare
for example one mainer unfortunately had
to face the reality
that medicare's coverage denial of a
particular
sensor that he needed for his insulin
pump
meant paying up to eight thousand
dollars
out of pocket each year if he wants to
continue with his current
treatment he wrote because
i am now 65 i am
denied care that was available
when i was 64.
he continued this approach not only puts
me
at risk but quite likely is not
cost effective while the sensors are
expensive
the cost of ambulance calls and
hospitalizations
is certainly more madam president
i could not say it better it makes no
sense for this individual who is aged
into the medicare system
to lose coverage that he had
and relied upon and used successfully
to control his diabetes
to better support the adoption of these
technologies
our bill would require hhs
to create a special task force on
coverage and payment
for innovative diabetes technologies
that would bring all stakeholders from
patients to device manufacturers
to government officials and health care
professionals
who are making coverage decisions to the
table
the task force would identify and plan
for changes in medicare coverage
and payment policies to ensure that
medicare beneficiaries have access to
the latest
treatments to the innovation
that are currently available as well as
those that are in the pipeline the task
force would also
be tasked with developing strategies for
supporting adoption of these
technologies
this effort builds on our past
advocacy to improve the day-to-day life
of individuals with diabetes
in january 2017
in response to the bipartisan effort
that senator shaheen
and i led cms first approved
the use of continuous glucose monitors
we also successfully urged cms
last year to support the use of
smartphone
apps in conjunction with continuous
glucose
monitors these are proven
life-saving devices that are relied upon
by people with diabetes to provide them
with real time
measurements of their glucose levels
this information is key to preventing
costly
sometimes deadly diabetes complications
madam president while i am pleased that
our advocacy
has helped spurred these policy changes
i remain frustrated that true up and
medicare
lags behind commercial
insurers greater adoption
of these new diabetes techniques
can help address the explosive growth
in the financial and human toll
of diabetes diabetes accounts for an
extraordinary
one in three dollars in medicare
spending it is paramount that we
encourage hhs to adopt a more
cost-effective
and compassionate approach to treating
this
chronic disease that affects more than
30 million
americans the improving medicare
beneficiary access to innovative
diabetes technologies act encourages
a proactive approach to diabetes
coverage
and payment i encourage my colleagues to
support
our efforts thank you madam president
and again my thanks to my partner
senator shaheen for her leadership in
this area
madam president senator from texas
madam president last week congress
notched another bipartisan win
for the american people a bill i
reintroduced earlier this year
along with senator markey from
massachusetts was signed into law
finally establishing juneteenth as a
national holiday
this bill was unanimously supported in
the senate and got an overwhelming vote
in the house of representatives and i
was honored to be with president biden
at the white house when he signed it
into law
late last week and it was even more
special to celebrate with my fellow
texans
over the weekend on saturday i was
honored to spend the very first
juneteenth national independence day in
galveston
where major general gordon granger and
his troops declared
that all slaves were forever free
this happened two and a half years after
the emancipation proclamation was signed
and just a couple of months after
hostilities between the north
and the south had ended but
communication being what it is
across a huge country particularly that
time
it took two and a half years for the
message to
get to the former slaves in galveston
texas where
juneteenth has been celebrated for many
many years and in my state alone
we celebrated juneteenth for 40 years as
a state holiday
i could not have been more happy to take
a piece of history with me a copy of the
bipartisan bill that helped preserve
the legacy of juneteenth for generations
to come
madam president this is just the
one item in a significant list of
bipartisan accomplishments
we've made in an equally divided senate
which as we all know is no small thing
to confront the growing threats of china
to ensure more businesses can
grab onto the lifeline of the paycheck
protection program one of the most
significant
economic assistances items of economic
assistance that we were able to provide
during the
covet 19 virus we provided states with
additional resources to upgrade their
drinking water and wastewater
infrastructure
and we passed legislation to combat hate
crimes
against asian americans so the truth is
notwithstanding what it may look like in
the news or on cable tv
or on social media every day
our colleagues here in the senate
continue to work across the aisle
to find consensus and to craft
legislation with bipartisan support
where we can i tell people that
legislation is hard to pass
by design and
our current rules require us to do the
hard work of
actually building consensus on a
bipartisan basis
before we can pass legislation
particularly in the senate
but we continue to do other our work in
other
important areas like infrastructure
which has
been the subject of so much attention
and debate
to do police reform to deal with the
high price of prescription drugs
republicans and democrats continue to
work together to address some of our
most urgent problems
but this week unfortunately the majority
leader the senator from new york has
decided to take another tack
he's chosen to spend the senate's time
on partisan legislation
that simply has no chance of becoming
law
that's his choice he gets to set the
agenda
and our only role is to show up
debate the bill and cast our ballot
our democratic colleagues have given it
the marquee treatment
a bill known as s-1 with the symbolic
numbering of the bill as the first
meaning the most important bill
in their agenda but rather than
a bipartisan bill
that will be good for the entire country
not just one political party
or the other
the majority leader has chosen to tee up
this massive
federal election takeover bill
this legislation first popped in 2019
when the newly elected democrat majority
in the house went on a messaging
bill spree a messaging bill is one that
you really know
will never become law but it sends a
message
and over the last two years they've
tried out a range of different marketing
strategies that's really all it is
it's not about passing legislation it's
about sending a message trying to gain
partisan political advantage but they've
tried a range of marketing strategies to
convince the american people that this
overhaul to our election system is
necessary
at one point it was a matter of election
security
then of voter confidence then
a way that remove obstacles that
prevented people from of color from
voting
well i've got some news for them in 2020
we saw a record election turnout
two-thirds of all eligible voters
cast a ballot that was the highest
turnout
in 120 years and it wasn't confined to
any single racial or ethnic group
it was across the board we saw
african-american voter participation
at virtually an all-time high same with
hispanics and every other ethnic and
racial group
so notwithstanding the facts that
people are turning out to vote in
historic
numbers they had to come up with a new
sales pitch
they had to attack the efforts in the
states
to pass their own election laws which
handle the time and manner in which
state elections are run
and to me the consistent theme was
making it easier to vote
and harder to cheat to me that's the
simple message i think we ought to be
sending
when it comes to our election laws so
that's what our
colleagues latched on to but over the
last few months they've twisted
and turned and manipulated the facts
beyond any recognition they've tried to
frame new state voting laws
as the impetus or the reason justifying
this massive federal takeover
my view takeover of state voting laws
they've painted an alarming picture of
the assault on voter access
but if you actually take time to look at
these so-called
restrictions in voting you'll find
they're more generous
than the current law in many democratic
controlled states
there's no better example than the
georgia law
which came under national scrutiny for
enacting reforms that would give
georgia voters more time to vote than
voters in a number of blue states
here are the facts madam president
in georgia the law that people claimed
was racist and designed to prevent
people of color from casting their
ballot during the early voting season
before in day on
election day voting the new georgia law
provides 17 days for in-person
early voting how about massachusetts
currently represented by two democratic
senators
well massachusetts provides 11 days
delaware represented by two democrats
the state home state of our president
it provides 10 days of early voting
new jersey also represented by two
democratic senators
provides nine days almost half
of what georgia has provided for
in its new election laws but what you
heard
across the news media cable tvs
social media and the like was that
somehow someway
georgia had conspired to restrict the
rights of african-american and other
minority voters from casting their
ballot
but the facts prove otherwise
but this is the type of hypocrisy that
we're seeing in this debate
as i said new jersey recently passed a
law
just recently passed a law that expanded
in person voting to nine days
did anyone claim that this was somehow a
jim crow
relic or a racist act or violating the
the rights of african american and other
minority voters
of course not did was new jersey treated
the same as georgia was in the popular
media where it was suggested that
somehow
this was a racist effort to restrict
minority access to voting of course not
but the new jersey governor took it a
step further
he actually criticized georgia for
restricting what he called restricting
the right of georgians to vote
but his own state provides half the
opportunity
that the new georgia law does to cast
your ballot
obviously this is a bunch of political
talk
and an attempt to try to intimidate
congress and the american people
into this federal takeover of state
election laws
but we've heard similar similar attack
lines from a number of our
democratic colleagues who have falsely
tried to brand this lot
this this law as a form of voter
suppression
even though it's more generous than
current laws
in a number of blue states
well here's some more facts
you've heard a lot of talk about mail-in
ballots
the georgia law sets a deadline of 11
days before the election
to request a mail-in ballot but in
the state of the majority leader senator
schumer
new york voters only receive a week
so you receive you got seven days
prior to election to request a mail-in
ballot in new york
11 days in georgia and for some reason
our democratic colleagues
focus on georgia and claim that this is
some sort of conspiracy
to diminish and restrict minority voting
which is clearly
false in new york you also have to have
a reason
for voting absentee but in georgia
no excuse need to be given you can do so
as a matter of right even if you're
going to be in town
even if you're otherwise able to vote if
you find it more convenient
to cast your ballot by mail in in
georgia you can do so but not in new
york
if any state tries to enact policies
that
suppress the votes of minority voters
there is a law in place currently
section two of the voting rights act
that gives the
u.s government the right to sue that
state or jurisdiction
and make sure that minority voters have
equal access
to the ballot matter of fact the voting
rights act has been one of the most
successful
laws ever passed by a federal congress
and the
historic turnout i referred to a few
moments ago
i think is the best evidence of that
minority voting
voters across the country are voting in
historically high numbers
which to me is the best evidence that
the voting rights act is doing exactly
what we hoped it would do when we passed
it and we were
when we reauthorized it just a few short
years ago
so if this isn't a solution
to efforts to restrict
restrict minority voting what exactly is
this bill
that we'll be voting on tomorrow s1
well the truth is it's a partisan
solution to a problem that doesn't exist
this law if passed s-1 which we will
vote on tomorrow
prevents the states from requiring
identification from voters to vote
in other words you don't have to show a
driver's license or
some other means of identification in
order to cast your ballot
but in the jimmy carter
james baker the third commission i think
it was 2005
that bipartisan commission recommended
voter id
as one of the important ways to maintain
the integrity
of the ballot so that the voting
officials know you are who you say you
are and indeed you can check your name
against the voter rolls to make sure
that you're legally authorized
to cast a ballot but senator schumer's
effort to
pass s-1 which we'll vote on tomorrow
prevents
the states from asking for voter
identification
even when virtually every state provides
that identification card
free if you don't drive they'll provide
you a free card
and you can use alternative means of
identification
but not if senator schumer's s-1 bill
were to pass
this bill s-1 would also tie the state's
hands when it comes to maintaining
accurate voter rolls
so if people have moved out of the state
or
if voters have passed away this law
would tie the hands of the states to
make sure that those names were removed
from the voters roles
which would make it more likely that
fraudulent efforts to cast those ballots
on behalf of
voters who either didn't exist or had
moved out of state is possible
but s-1 would tie the hands of the
states
to periodically purge dead voters from
the voter rolls
this would also encourage something
called
ballot harvesting now some states
provide for ballot harvesting but many
thankfully do not but ballot harvesting
simply makes it possible for a partisan
in a political campaign to go around and
collect ballots
maybe at nursing homes maybe at shopping
malls maybe at other places and then
they deliver those ballots to the voting
clerk at the at the designated place in
time
but you can imagine if the chain of
custody
of those ballots is not traced
and tracked and monitored
just think of the opportunities that
could provide for fraud
this bill also would alter the makeup of
the bipartisan federal election
commission
to give the democratic party an
advantage right now they're equal
numbers of republicans and democrats
on the federal election commission
that's the way it should be
but this bill s one would give the
democrats
a partisan advantage a big mistake
and here's maybe the the biggest insult
to the taxpayers
so whether or not you support a
particular political candidate
or the platform that candidate runs on
you can be forced to contribute your tax
dollars
to that political candidate to help them
run and win the election
this is government funding really
taxpayer funding of political campaigns
and i believe it's a two to six ratio if
i'm not mistaken
for every two dollars that the candidate
raises they get six dollars
in taxpayer funding to run their
campaign
and that's your hard-earned money that
you may that you've
paid in taxes that's being used
to promote ideas and candidates that you
don't support
well i could go on and on the list of
absurdities is a long one
but our friend the senior senator from
california summed it up pretty well
earlier this month
she said if democracy were in jeopardy
i would want to protect it but i don't
see it being in jeopardy right now
close quote so madam president there is
no voter suppression
crisis certainly not a systemic one and
if there is
a problem with suppressing minority
votes there is
authority available under the voting
rights act
for the attorney general appointed by
joe biden and confirmed by the senate to
be able to go after them
there's no widespread effort to stop
voters from casting a ballot
and there's no desire to hand state's
constitutional
authorities over to the federal
government
our democratic colleagues are struggling
to accept this reality
they spent the last several days working
behind the scenes to negotiate a
compromise
among themselves well there was never a
question of whether or not this would be
a bipartisan bill
because of the overreach that i've just
talked about
the question was whether or not the
bipartisan opposition
seen in the house would continue in the
senate
but even if democrats were to accept all
of the changes proposed by
senator manchin the senator from west
virginia and endorsed by stacy abrams
the rotten core of this bill remains the
same
this is a politically motivated federal
takeover
of our elections and it will not stand
the constitution doesn't give the
democratic party
or the republican party to govern how
states
run their elections that's reserved to
the states by the constitution of the
united states of america
i will firmly oppose any effort to hand
texas's constitutional rights
to regulate and conduct its elections to
the federal government
but one size fits all federal mandate
won't improve public confidence
in our elections it will be seen for the
for what it is in a transparent
way a partisan political takeover
a coup d'etat really of the way that our
elections are run
elections should be run by the folks who
are elected
and who are accountable to the states in
my state texas
and certainly not partisan political
actors with an agenda
here in washington d.c
madam president i yield the floor and i
note the absence of a quorum
click will call the role ms baldwin
you
madam president the senator from new
york i ask unanimous consent the quorum
be dispensed with
without objection madam president i move
to proceed to legislative session
the question is on the measure all in
favor say aye
aye opposed no the eyes appear to have
it
the eyes do have it the motion is agreed
to
i move to proceed to yeah
i move to proceed to executive session
to consider calendar 172.
questions on a measure all in favor say
aye
aye opposed no the
eyes appear to have it the eyes do have
it
the motion is agreed to the clever
the report the nomination nomination the
judiciary deborah l boardman of maryland
to be united states district judge for
the district of maryland
i send a cloture motion to the desk the
clerk will report
closure motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring you a closed
debate on the nomination of executive
calendar number 172
deborah l boardman of maryland to be
united states district judge for the
district of maryland signed by 17
senators as follows
i as consent the reading of the names be
waived without objection
i move to proceed to legislative session
the question is on the motion
all in favor say aye aye opposed no
the eyes appeared have it the eyes do
have it
the motion is agreed to i move to
proceed to executive session to consider
calendar 128
questions on the motion all in favor say
aye
aye opposed no the eyes appear to have
it
the eyes do have it the motion is agreed
to
clerk will report the nomination
nomination the judiciary
candace jackson okawumi of illinois to
be united states to circuit judge for
the seventh circuit
i send a cloture motion to the desk the
clip will report
your motion we the undersigned senators
in accordance with the provisions of
rule 22 the standing rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close
debate on the nomination of executive
calendar number 128
candace jackson akomi of illinois to be
united states circuit judge for the 7th
circuit signed by 17 senators as follows
i asked consent the reading of the names
be waived without objection
i ask unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum calls for the cloture motion
motions filed today january 21 be waived
without objection
i yield the floor
senator from alabama
madam president before i begin i want to
first take a moment
and remember those that lost their lives
in a horrific
car accident in butler county alabama
this past weekend
10 people lost their lives nine of those
were between
ages nine months and 17 years old
a majority of those killed were in a
tallapoosa county girls ranch bus
the girls ranch is an organization that
i've been involved with for
20 years it handles
young kids that have been abused young
kids that have no parents
they start at this ranch at most any age
and everything's paid for all the way
through graduation of college
these kids were on a field trip coming
from
balwin county alabama this past weekend
involved in this horrific crash there's
no words that can bring the comfort to
these families
are these children but my family and my
staff
and the people of alabama are praying
for peace for all these affected
during this unimaginable time
madam president as i and others have
noted democrats
call their flagship voting bill for the
people act
but a better and more fitting title is
the nancy pelosi
power grab act my republican colleagues
have done a good job of highlighting the
many flaws of this legislation
in the past couple of weeks including
doing away with common sense fraud
protection like voter id
forcing mandatory same-day registration
on every state
allowing paid political operatives to
harvest voter ballots
and directing taxpayer dollars to the
campaigns
of progressive politicians sadly there's
plenty more
but let me also note that this recent
quote compromise
is anything but a compromise
among democrats should have been their
starting
offer to republicans not their final
offer
the most recent versions still run afoul
of the constitution by trampling on the
first amendment
rights of free speech and taking away
redistricting
from the states and while id
is still required to vote the bill
expands what kind of id
meets that requirement such as a utility
bill
but the last time i looked there was not
a photo
on our utility bill
the most secure form of identification
of identification
is a government issued photo id
states shouldn't be forced to water that
down
america's americans want faith and trust
in the integrity of their election
process
this bill does not provide solutions to
strengthen
these processes and once americans learn
what's in this bill
they will agree the pelosi power grab
yanks power from the states
the pelosi power grab lets politicians
stuff their pockets with taxpayers
dollars and guess what folks a slightly
different version of a federal takeover
of election is
still a federal takeover of elections
that's exactly what this new version of
s-1
is it's hard to even call this version
of s-1 a compromise when the democrats
only compromise with members
of their own party this was not a
bipartisan negotiation
to get an end product that both sides of
the aisle could support
the last time i checked we still have a
50-50 senate
there has been no negotiation with our
side
but regardless of its form this bill
does not solve
the problems currently facing our
election system
it makes the problems worse
you know in sports one team changing the
rules by themself
is called cheating it is seen for what
is
a power grab it is stacking the rules to
win
the game instead of doing the hard work
necessary
to get the job done folks may be
scratching their head as to
why one political party thinks they can
completely change the rules
of elections all by themselves
but if you've been paying attention to
what the progressives
have been up to recently it won't come
as a big surprise
changing our country as we know it is
the end game
that's why they want to pass this pelosi
power grab
so those who disagree with them have a
harder
time winning at the ballot box
but it's not just elections remember
when they tried to hoodwink us with
defund the police last year
remember when they tried to walk that
back
but they had made their position very
clear
and now we're seeing the same thing with
education
as critical race theory is pushed on
school districts
across the country simply put critical
race theory it reinforces
divisions on strict racial lines
it doesn't teach kids moral values like
treating everyone with respect
regardless of race it's just
the opposite critical race theory
teaches kids to
hate one another that's one thing
schools
should absolutely absolutely
not be teaching but again
for democrats it's about changing the
way we view
our country what we should be focusing
on
is actually improving education
all over this country the american
people need to realize
how far we've fallen behind
as a columnist mark stein wrote quote
education is the biggest structural
defect in our society we have
almost entirely corrupt and abusive
education establishment
here's where that education
establishment has got us
we're 37th in the world in math 13th in
reading
18 in science in 2019
only 35
of our 4th graders 35 of our 4th graders
were able to read at the 4th grade
reading level
35 embarrassing
that was lower than two years before and
it was before the teachers unions
kept kids out of school all this past
year
you can imagine how it is today
it is unacceptable it should be
unacceptable to every member
of this body we've got china
outpatient us in every industry and at
every level of our economy
but democrats are too busy painting the
united states
as the world's villain how can we
expect our young people to defend united
states abroad
if they don't learn about the things
that make
america the greatest country in the
history of the world
we as elected representatives
of americans across the country should
be doing everything
and i mean everything we can to create
opportunity
and protect the freedoms that make this
country great
it seems like folks across the aisle are
interested in that they have a
completely
different vision of and for
our country one that most americans
don't agree with at all i bet if you ask
folks back home
if they want a bigger government and
less state and local power
they'd say no way
i bet if you ask them if a federal power
grab
sounds like a good idea they would say
no i bet if you ask them if they want
their kids to learn to be more divided
by race
they would also say no they would
tell you that they want their freedoms
protected
they would tell you that want the
federal government out of the way
they want an education for children that
provides opportunity
because education is the key to freedom
and success education can unlock
every student's god-given potential
but critical race theory swallows that
key
the pelosi power grab just fills the
lock
with cement ladies and gentlemen for
this
for the people act is one party's
attempt to rewrite the rules
rewrite the rules of the game in hope
that they'll get a permanent advantage
plain and simple it's really a shame
we're spending so much time on bills
that the american people don't want
bills that don't have bipartisan support
so i urge my colleagues to come together
and find solutions that will unite us as
americans
not divide us further as a country
thank you madam president
nobody's up
for quorum call break one front row
this baldwin
senator from tennessee ask unanimous
consent to vitiate the quorum call
without objection
thank you madam president i'm here today
to address democrats deceptively labeled
for the people act which should more
accurately be
labeled before the politicians act
this legislation represents a
breathtaking unprecedented power grab
in a 50-50 senate this is a blatant
attempt by those who are in power by the
slimmest possible margin
to take over and rewrite the election
and campaign rules for all 50 states
in one fell swoop this would be done in
an entirely partisan basis to ensure
candidates
from that same party win elections
in fact while the only supporters of the
bill are democrats
there are by there is bipartisan
opposition to this legislation
this legislation would disenfranchise
every american
through the federal seizure of the
authority of each state's
representatives
to set election rules for their states
in accordance
with the wishes of their citizens and
this partisan legislation would wash
away election integrity measures
making it easier to cheat each invalid
vote cast
dilutes the strength of each valid vote
cast
our form of government for the people
and by the people rest upon voters faith
in the integrity of our elections if we
allow that faith
in our elections to continue to be
compromised we're allowing the very
foundation of our american system to be
eroded
democrats don't want to talk about the
details of this legislation
they don't want you to peek under the
hood they want to just slap a voting
rights bumper sticker on it
jam it through and then disparage and
name call anyone who opposes it
so let's take a look at exactly what's
in this legislation
under this legislation a federal
politician running for election
could take millions in taxpayer money
for his or her own campaign
the legislation says that states must
then allow that politician
to pay political operatives to visit
nursing homes
dormitories emergency shelters other
residences to collect
thousands of ballots and then choose
which ones to be dropped into unmanned
drop boxes maybe in the middle of the
night
this bill would make it illegal for
states to verify the identity of voters
at the polls
under this bill ballots arriving even a
week after election day
would still be counted it would require
states to adopt universal mail-in voting
states would be forced to allow
murderers rapists and child molesters to
vote
even if estate citizens have adopted
laws to prevent it
it would require states to allow
unregistered voters to cast ballots by
simply showing up on election day
and signing a form without an id
and with no vetting allowed the bill
would silence political speech by
religious and non-profit organizations
while politicians can use taxpayer
dollars to air attack ads
with which many americans would find
distasteful
the bill provides that if anyone
disputes any of this that's okay
they can lodge their complaints with the
federal election commission
a body that has been bipartisan since
its creation
but wait in addition to changing the
rules to benefit one team
the legislation also buys off the umpire
by transforming the fec into a partisan
democrat-controlled body
a body that could hound the opposing
party candidates to the ends of the
earth
this bill transforms the judge into the
prosecutor
i wish that was all the legislation did
it also snatches the responsibility for
drawing congressional districts for the
elected representatives of all 50 states
who have done that job for the last 230
years
and it sets up a byzantine process that
would ultimately hand it over to an
academic consultant
hired by a liberal judge right here in
washington
let me repeat that a consultant hired by
a judge in washington d.c
will be drawing every congressional
district in the country
using government power to seize control
of elections to limit speech
to pack tribunals to ensure the ruling
party stays in power
well that sounds like a headline you'd
hear in venezuela
in russia iran or even china not the
united states of america
not too long ago both parties would have
considered this partisan power grab
beyond the pale
but far left operatives want permanent
power
and democrats eager to keep the power to
themselves
are afraid to tell them no democrats are
now characterizing this legislation
as an emergency response to recent
legislation in a few states
this legislation isn't just a solution
in search of a problem
it's a power grab that for years has
been
in search of a crisis any crisis
manufactured or otherwise
that can be used to justify it democrat
operatives
introduced a previous bill on january 24
2017. four days after president trump
took office
the purported crisis then was the
american people's election of donald
trump
which the democrats found unacceptable
they continued this effort by
introducing yet another version of the
for the politicians act in 2019
which that time passed the house without
a single republican vote
like the bill the senate will consider
this week this bill was a democrat
operatives
electioneering fantasy federalizing
unlimited mail voting prohibiting
voter id requirements and allowing
unregistered voters to show up and vote
on election day
wisely the senate in 2019 never took it
up
then as the pandemic took root in the
spring of 2020
democrats in search of yet a new crisis
to justify this bill
included it in a pandemic relief bill
that the house passed
again without a single republican vote
once again the senate dismissed it and
wisely focused on providing partisan
pandemic relief
rather than using the pandemic as a
justification to federalize elections
with the pandemic now in the rearview
mirror this legislation is being pitched
as necessary to preserve
voting rights using cartoonish
overheated and false characterizations
of a few
sensible measured voting integrity laws
that have recently been acted by states
why because democrats have to invent a
new crisis every six months or so
to conceal this quest to install
themselves permanently into power
don't let them fool you this isn't about
some state election law
the house passed virtually the same bill
last year
most of the components of this bill have
been floating around democrat national
committee back rooms
for years this isn't about voting rights
this legislation protects voting rights
like banning security
guards at banks would protect bank
depositors
now why are the democrats so desperate
to pass this bill
well a recent report from politico
explains it
politico says what's at stake is
potentially the future democratic
majorities
many in the party privately worry that
frontline democrats
could lose their seats if congress
doesn't pass this bill
so to keep power democrats have
determined they have to take over state
elections
this is about holding on to power and
nothing else
there doesn't seem to be a power grab
that's too extreme for the modern left
whether it's this bill legislation to
pack the supreme court
suddenly changing their position and
pushing to scrap fundamental senate
rules
in order to obtain short-term political
gains
or adding washington d.c as a state it's
all about
one thing fulfilling a fantasy of
permanent
democrat power under this legislation
american elections would no longer be
about earning the support of voters by
communicating a powerful vision
rather american elections would be all
about creating the largest machine
identifying favorable voters and mass
gathering their ballots door-to-door
as efficiently as possible the winning
campaign would be the one with the
largest army of ballot harvesters to
drive voters registered or
unregistered with or without id
to fill out and hand over a ballot that
will be dropped
on their behalf in unmanned ballot boxes
americans want common sense laws that
make it easier to vote
and harder to cheat such laws currently
exist throughout the country
that's why we had record-breaking voter
participation in 2020
including in my state of tennessee this
legislation
is as unnecessary as it is misguided
and dangerous it's a politician
protection measure
that would do irreparable damage to the
fabric of this country
and it should be soundly rejected by
this body
madam chair i yield the floor and
suggest the absence of a quorum
click we'll call the roll miss baldwin
madam president senator from maryland uh
yes you know i'm
sent to the quorum call without
objection
madam president uh this saturday was
juneteenth the first official
juneteenth recognized by the federal
government
as a national holiday the official end
of slavery in america
i commemorated and celebrated juneteenth
with my colleague senator van hollen
at a meeting of the naacp chapter
in reynoldstown maryland and we
reflected on
the progress that we've made since the
end of slavery
and the challenges that still remain
it's been a long path towards justice
and equality in this country
and i think we all recognize the wisdom
of dr martin luther king jr
with his famous quote that the moral arc
of the moral universe is long but it
bends
towards justice i think we all believe
that
but in recent actions taken by state
governments
to restrict voting rights we've seen
some very disturbing trends
that would take issue with dr king's
statement
that the moral universe
is bending towards justice it seems like
it's taken
a detour voting rights is a fundamental
issue of importance to a democratic
country
madam president after elections are over
and we win we celebrate
we celebrate the fact that we've gotten
the support
of the majority of the voters and that
was what democracy is all about
if we don't win and i think many of us
have been involved in campaigns where
our candidates have not
been successful we go to work
to try to attract more voters in the
next election so we can celebrate a
victory
that's what participation in a free
society is all about that's what
democracies are about
in repressive autocratic regimes
they'll never accept the will of the
people
so they look at ways in which they can
undermine
the voter record what the voters want to
do
the voters will in the 2020
elections we should all celebrate the
record number
of people who cast their ballots
it was a record most ever casting their
votes for the presidency of the united
states
there was repeated reviews done
by both democrats and republicans
at the national level at the state level
at the local level
and it verified the simple fact that
there was no widespread corruption
that the will of the people prevailed
and joe biden
kamala harris were elected president and
vice president of the united states
but that did not stop former president
trump
and promoting the big lie as a result of
that
several states have now taken action
to make it harder for people to cast
their votes
the brennan center india has pointed out
that we've seen the worst
assault on voting rights since
jim crow
14 states have enacted 22 new laws
to make it more difficult more difficult
for people to vote
this is unprecedented in modern times
so what have those laws done
made it more difficult for voters to
vote by mail
recognizing that in for many voters they
prefer to vote by mail we have states
that have 100 percent
voting by mail there has been no
indication
of fraud and voting by mail
states have shortened the time for
requesting
mail and balance for voting making it
more difficult
for individuals to be able to vote by
mail
requiring certain requirements to vote
by mail
making it more difficult to deliver
their mail ballots
limiting the availability a mail ballot
drop boxes
all that had been included why
because it makes it more difficult for
people who are likely to vote for my
opponent
to vote that's what the state
legislatures were
doing stricter signature requirements
making in-person voting more difficult
and purging voter rolls simply because a
person did not vote
again making it more difficult for
people to vote
and it goes on and on and on on the
types
of legislation that has already passed
or is currently being considered by many
state legislatures
around the country making it more
difficult to register to vote
making it more difficult to vote
targeting potential voters more likely
to vote for their opponents
targeting minorities young voters
and older minority voters let me just
give one example
using georgia as a specific example
their recently enacted changes will
disproportionately hurt
black voters the georgia state law
imposes voter identification
requirements
on absentee ballots makes it hard to
request an absentee ballot
and makes it a crime for groups to
provide food and water
to voters waiting in line georgia is
basically restricting mail voting in
response to a shift in the racial
demographics of the voters
who use it on the other hand georgia
wants to keep mail voting available for
older
white male voters voter suppression is
always
unacceptable and the razor thin
political margins in georgia
may mean that the suppression efforts
like these will change political
outcomes
rather than imposing barriers to casting
the sacred right to vote
georgia should be looking at ways to
improve
voter access as the new york times
pointed out
the georgia law comes on the heels of a
major upset
for republicans in the traditionally
read state after voters picked joe biden
in the presidential election and elected
democrats
to both the state's u.s senate seats the
paper noted that the new georgia law
will in particular curtail ballot access
for voters
in booming urban and suburban counties
home
to many democrats president
biden was right to call this legislation
the jim crow
in the 21st century there are many other
examples georgia's not unique in the
efforts we're seeing
to suppress voter participation at
elections
look it's fair game to try to persuade
voters to vote for your candidate it's
not fair game
to suppress their right to vote
so what is the vote this week all about
the vote that we're going to have
on bringing forward the opportunity to
debate
voter suppression legislation to protect
the right to vote
it's simply a motion to proceed
with a debate on the senate floor let me
repeat that
we're not voting on s1
the passage of it we're not voting on
any specific proposal
i know my friend from west virginia has
offered a proposal we're not voting on
that
we're voting on the right for the senate
to take up
this critically important issue
or whether it should be filibustered so
we can't bring up
a voter issue to protect the integrity
of the right to vote
now i support s1 i'm a co-sponsor of s1
for the people
i'm proud to support the provisions of
that bill to me
it's a carefully drafted legislation
to deal with the modern threats to voter
participation
and i am extremely proud that my
colleague from maryland
congressman john sarbanes is the
principal sponsor of hr1
in the house that already passed the
house
it provides a basic federal floor on
protection
of the right to vote on voter
registration
on voter by mail no excuse balloting
two weeks of early voting
including weekends no notary requirement
for absentee ballots
drop off boxes this is simple
voter protection against
the actions being taken by state
legislatures
that are aimed at certain demographic
groups
a federal floor it ends political
gerrymandering
i don't know how any of my colleagues
can defend
the way that legislative and
congressional lines are drawn today
i came from the state legislature i'm a
former speaker of the house
i was responsible for one of the
redistricting plans in maryland
when i was speaker of the house it's
and just a horrible partisan political
process that we use today to draw
congressional lines i've been accused by
my congressional colleagues
in the house from maryland that i ran
for the senate to avoid having to deal
with congressional redistricting there
may be some truth to that
but i can tell you this it is timed
and political gerrymandering
congressional districts should represent
the community's interests
not an individual congressman's interest
s-1
takes a major step forward in ending
political
congressional redistricting by
gerrymandering
it provides a commitment by congress
to advance pre-clearance formula
that was in the voting rights act of
1965
that now is not operative because of the
shelby county decision
it puts us on a path to once again have
that important tool available
in order to deal with
the freedom and right of vote
it promotes voter security yes one by
eliminating the paper ballot by
requiring the paper ballot i should say
not eliminating it by requiring a paper
trail i think we all agree that we want
to be able to verify votes
the only way you can if there's a paper
trail and it provides for that paper
trail
it puts an end to the dominance of big
money in the political system
they do that in a couple ways one
disclosure
how can anyone be against the disclosure
of who's putting money into our
political system
and secondly providing a way in which we
can get
rid of the dependence upon large
special interest dollars it includes
s1 two provisions that i authored one
deceptive practices act that deals with
false and misleading advertisements
which are aimed
at targeting minority communities to
confuse
and mislead their votes and it includes
the democracy restoration act that i
authored
that deals with laws passed
after the end of slavery and an effort
to prevent
african americans from voting for you
see there are states that pass laws back
then that are still in the books
that disqualifies for a lifetime
a person convicted of a felony the
definition of felony is pretty
general in many states so we have a
states that where one out of five
african americans have been disqualified
from voting
because of their conviction of a felony
even though they are in
they are fully part of our society today
they don't have the right to vote we
need to
remove that disqualification
on voting my friend
our former colleague john lewis the two
of us were elected to the united states
house of representatives
on the same day in an editorial
published
after his death our former colleague
john lewis recalled
an important lesson taught by dr martin
luther king jr
and i quote our former colleague he said
each of us has a moral
obligation to stand up
speak up and speak out
when you see something that is not right
you must say something
you must do something democracy is not a
state
it is an act and each generation must do
its part well
madam president we cannot take
action if we don't start
and we can't start unless
my colleagues allow us to proceed
to this issue on the floor of the united
states senate
there's a reason why there are so many
groups behind us taking action
i had facebook live that i do every two
weeks with my constituents
jenna morgan from the declaration for
american democracy
which represents over 180 groups
from labor to racial justice groups
faith groups women rights groups
environmental good governance groups all
telling us
we need to move forward to protect our
democracy
that the senate needs to act on this
issue
one of my guests virginia k solomon from
the league of women voters
now the league of women voters you can
say a lot of things about them but you
can't accuse them of being partisan
because they're not
it's one of our premier non-partisan
institutions in america with a proud
history
they're telling us to take this bill up
and act
for the sake of protecting our democracy
we then have a chance to act to take up
amendments and vote on amendments and
vote on concerns whether they're
offered by a republican senator or
democratic senator
that's what the motion proceeds allows
us to do to take up these issues
so we can vote on them but if you vote
to filibuster the motion to proceed we
can't even bring the issue up on the
senate floor
for action madam president i urge my
colleagues not to filibuster the right
of the united states senate
to start the debate on protecting
voter integrity where each member will
have an opportunity
to debate the issue and collectively we
can come together
as many of my colleagues have offered
suggestions
about how we can improve s1 how we can
make it
a broader consensus but we can't do that
unless we have the right
to proceed to a debate i urge my
colleagues
to support the cloture motion on the
motion to proceed
so the senate can take up this most
critically important issue
to the preservation of our democracy and
the integrity of the right to vote
with that i yield the floor
leader from tennessee i ask unanimous
consent that
i be allowed to complete my remarks
prior to the roll call vote
without objection thank you madam
president
if the constitution is the foundation of
our
republic then the concept of one person
one vote is the cornerstone it's also a
promise that
every single eligible voter in america
takes with them
into that voting booth on election day
it gives them confidence that their vote
matters
it helps them to keep the faith in our
electoral system and in their
local government we can talk about the
vote on a grand scale
here in washington but that's where it
really
matters back home at your local
polling place in your home county
and in the precincts with the people who
do the work of
standing up elections running elections
and certifying their own
elections madam president it is
of the people by the people for the
people
that this process is carried out
in each and every one of our counties
and you know what madam president that
is
how it is supposed to be article 1
section 4
of our constitution clearly states
here it is the times places and
manner of holding elections for senators
and representatives
shall be prescribed in each state
by the legislature thereof well how
about that
the constitution delegates that
authority
to the state legislatures
and that is why our state secretaries of
state work with our counties to make
certain that the process is put in place
you know i have had the opportunity to
serve
on my county's local election commission
prior to my being in elective office
one person one vote that is the number
one
rule that guided the decisions they made
when we recruited poll workers it's the
number one concern
that drives people to go st sign
up when we train the volunteers that are
staffing polling places
it's the number one rule to teach
every person gets one vote
all legally cast votes
are counted that's the way
it is supposed to work one person
one vote here in the senate i'm
concerned that my democratic colleagues
have forgotten
about this rule why else would they once
again pledge
to move a piece of legislation that
would throw
one person one vote out the window
many of my republican colleagues have
taken to calling
h1 or s1 the politicians
protection act or the for the
politicians
act and i will have to agree
that is a fairly apt description
now there are a lot of problems with
this bill but i want to focus on a few
key provisions that will gut one person
one vote and destroy confidence
in our elections if this bill passes
say goodbye to meaningful
voter id laws now my democratic
colleagues kept the idea of these
requirements intact
but to please their radical base they
added
a loophole that would force every single
jurisdiction
to accept affidavits in lieu
of identification that is right an
affidavit
they may as well abandon voter ids
because that loophole makes requirements
that voters prove they are who they say
they are absolutely meaningless
they can just sign a statement saying
i am who i say i am without
having to show proof the bill also
requires states to allow
paid campaign operatives to engage in
ballot harvesting schemes that is right
this allows your paid campaign
operatives to engage in ballot
harvesting schemes
now these ballot harvesting schemes have
been proven time and again
to increase the risk of fraud so
much so that many states
on their own moved forward
and banned ballot harvesting schemes
why did they ban this because
it leads to fraud in elections
inexplicably my colleagues also want to
throw
ballot drop boxes into the mix
they've pitched them as a convenience
but that convenience will be nearly
impossible to monitor
and to protect 24 hours a day
which means that it will be nearly
impossible
to monitor and protect the ballots that
are inside those
boxes and these boxes
then become a fairly convenient
way to stuff the ballot box
but perhaps the most dangerous
counterproductive
and outright infuriating provision my
democratic colleagues have included
in this mess of a bill is a restriction
against voter roll maintenance
anyone with a bit of common sense knows
how
inaccurate or duplicate entries in a
data set can
add up that leaves these data sets
in a state of disrepair and that is how
fraud and mistakes occur
it's just one more provision in a bill
raising red flags for local officials in
every single state in this country and
this red flag
in particular is prompting people to ask
me if my democratic colleagues
involved in drafting this bill have ever
actually volunteered at a local polling
place
which that really tells you a lot about
how short-sighted
this legislation is madam president
this bill really doesn't have anything
to do with voting rights
this is a politically motivated federal
takeover of elections that would give us
the exact
opposite of what's laid out in the
constitution
the founders the founders
granted the state power over their own
elections for a reason the federal
government is beyond incompetent
to get this job done if you like the
service you get from the irs
or the epa or osha that's what you could
expect
the next time your community has an
election
if we allow this bill to pass the
promise of
one person one vote will crumble
the promise of counting eligible
ballots and not counting
balance would go by the wayside and what
do you get
in exchange the promise of chaos
confusion
and a lack of confidence in the
integrity
of the vote madam president i ask
unanimous consent that the remainder of
my remarks be placed
separately in the record without
objection
the time has come for team blackburn to
say
goodbye to our fearless leader and
current chief of staff chuck flint
chuck first joined my team in the house
as a member of our legislative staff
he was eager to prove himself capable
and well-versed on our legislative
issues and
i will tell you he succeeded in the
seven years
since he first walked through my office
door
he has grown into one of the finest
office and chief of staff
that i have seen on the hill and one of
the finest
political strategists here on capitol
hill
one of my most trusted advisors
and i will add the most enthusiastic
softball player on
team whiskey business the most
enthusiastic i think we've ever fielded
i was chuck jessica and little everett
all the hope and happiness in the world
as they embark on their next beautiful
adventure together
we will miss him tremendously but no
matter
how far they travel they will always
have a home
with team blackburn and in service to
the
volunteer state i yield the floor
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
closure motion we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 of the standing
rules of the senate
to hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on the nomination of executive
calendar number 149
christopher charles fonzone of
pennsylvania to be general counsel
of the officer of the office of the
director of national intelligence signed
by 17 senators
but unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been waived
the question is is it the sense of the
senate that debate on the nomination of
christopher charles von zone
of pennsylvania to be general counsel of
the office of the director of national
intelligence
shall be brought to a close the yeas of
nation mandatory under the rule the
clerk will call the roll
miss baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blonde
mr booker
mr booker
mr boseman
mr braun
mr brown
mr burr
miss cantwell this is capitao
mr garden
mr carpenter
mr casey
mr cassidy
ms collins
mr coons
mr cornyn
cortes masto
mr cotton
mr kramer
mr crapo
mr cruz
mr james
this is duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibram
mr graham
mr grassley
mr haggerty
miss hassan
hawley
mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
okay
mr
kind of like your hubbard
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
so
strainhole
mr johnson
mr kane
mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
who's klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
islamist
mr mansion
mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran
mrs murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
mr awesome
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
mr reed
mr romney
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen mr shelby
miss cinema
ms smith
ms stabenow mr sullivan
mr tester
mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock
miss warren
mr whitehouse
mr wicker mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin blunt cardin carper
collins duckworth durbin hassan
heinrich hickenlooper kane kelly
klobuchar mansion marky
murkowski murray padilla
heaters rosen schatz schumer
shaheen smith stabenow
tester warner warnock
warren senators voting in the negative
barrasso blackburn bozeman capitol
cotton crapo ernst fisher
hagerty heidsmith kennedy lankford
marshall moran portman
romney rubio scott of florida
scott of south carolina shelby thune
tillis tubberville wicker
miss cinema miss cinema i
mr king mr king aye mr graham mr graham
no
mr cornyn mr corning i
you
mr raid mr reed aye
islamists miss lomas no
mr sanders mr sanders i
mr wyden mr wyden i
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
mr menendez mr menendez aye
mr leahy mr leahy i
mr coons mr coons i
you
mr toomey mr toomey no
mr rono mr rono aye
mr johnson mr johnson
no mr van hollen mr van hollen
aye ms cortez masto miss cortez masto
aye
mr grassley mr grassley no
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
no mrs feinstein mr speinstein
i
mr whitehouse mr whitehouse i
mr lujan mr luhan i
miss cantwell miss cantwell i
you
you
mr merkley mr merkley i
mr lee mr lee no
you
mr cruz mr cruz no
mrs jill around mrs jill around i
you
mr burr mr burr i
mr murphy mr murphy
i
mr hawley mr hawley no
mr bennett mr bennett aye
you
you
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
mr ossoff mr assaf i'm
you
you
on this vote the yeas are 52 the nays
are 35. the motion
is agreed to
so
the senator from new york mr president
as if in legislative session
i ask unanimous consent that a time to
be determined by the majority leader
in consultation with the republican
leader the senate armed services
committee be discharged from further
consideration of s
1520 and the senate proceed to its
consideration that there will be two
hours for debate equally divided
in the usual form and that upon the use
or yielding back of that time
the senate vote on the bill with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection mr president our
president reserved my right to reject
i thank my colleague from new york uh
but once again i object to a request for
the reasons i have previously stated
i also want to thank her for the
courtesy of pres presenting the animus
consent immediately i appreciate that
very much
mr president
i am the first chairman of the senator
services committee to endorse the types
of changes the senator from new york
has proposed as they apply to sex
related offenses
under the ucmj as i have said it is my
intent to include the administration's
proposals
in the base markup of the defense bill
next month subject to an amendment
and i anticipate numerous amendments
being offered by members from both sides
of the aisle
further as i've already committed the
committee will consider these proposals
to include a vote on them in committee
if that is what any senator
desires that is in fact the tradition of
the committee
if a member wants a vote on an amendment
we will vote
i would note that according to committee
records there has not been a vote on
this proposal
in the committee since 2013 eight years
ago
and has not even been introduced as an
amendment in committee since that time
i look forward to having this debate
when the committee meets to mark up the
fiscal year 2022 defense bill
with that mr president i would reiterate
my objection
and again thank the senator for her
willingness to introduce the university
consent initially
mr president objection is heard so it's
very kind the chairman
notes that the last time we got a vote
in committee was 2013
we've been asking for a vote on this for
the last eight years asking for the last
five years to get a floor vote and been
denied
this bill has been routinely and roundly
filibustered and opposed by the chairman
and the ranking member for the entire
eight years that i've been working on
this bill and this bicameral bill that
has 66
senate co-sponsors should not be
relegated to a committee
that will communicate with a dod behind
the scenes that is what they do that's
what they have been doing
this is not a bill related to a
technical aspect of war fighting
that would benefit from the expertise
found within the dod
it is a check on the commander's power
that has been allowed a culture to
flourish
where two in three victims do not feel
comfortable coming forward
to report their assault and 64 percent
a number that is stubbornly unchanged
experience retaliation when they do come
forward
moreover a majority of the sask members
already co-sponsor this bill so it's
unclear
what expertise the committee will add
it will only create an opportunity for
the dod to water down this much needed
reform
as a military law expert brennan
faisal wrote today in the hill quote an
institution with the power to kill
people and topple governments
should not resist our elected senators
clear will
cheering as a procedural loophole allows
a small minority to prevent popular
reforms from being implemented
mr president this is the twelfth time
that i have risen
to ask for unanimous consent for a very
simple reason
the military justice improvement and
increasing prevention act
deserves a vote the people in the
military
deserve a military justice system worthy
of their sacrifice
we don't have time to delay every day
that we delay a vote on this
more service members are being sexually
assaulted and raped
i started this request for unanswered
consent 28 days ago
since then an estimated 1568 service
members have been raped or sexually
assaulted
more will have been victims of other
serious crimes
and most of them will feel that there's
no point
in even reporting the crime because they
have no faith in the current military
justice system
that system asks commanders not lawyers
to decide whether cases should go
forward
the lack of faith is understandable
less than one in ten sexual assault
cases are considered for command action
that are actually sent to trial and just
a small
fraction of those ending conviction and
in the eight years that we've been
fighting for this reform
further fault lines in the military
justice system have been made evident
including deeply troubling racial
disparities
it's a disappointment that the chairman
is not here to hear this information
himself
but in 2017 a report found black
service members were as much as 2.61
times
more likely to have disciplinary action
taken against them
as their white counterparts and in 2019
the gao found black and hispanic service
members
were more likely than white service
members to be subjected to criminal
investigation and to face
general and special court martials those
statistics show a clear and pressing
need to address
what appears to be inherent bias in the
current command
controlled system to provide our service
members with real justice
we must move all serious crimes out of
the chain of command
this bill will do that by making a
simple
but critical change to the way the
military justice
system handle serious crime it streams
line
streamlines how cases move forward
instead of commanders who have
zero formal legal training making the
decision to prefer or refer
cases to trial decisions this bill gives
those legal decisions
to highly trained impartial professional
military justice lawyers and
it allows the commander to continue to
work hand in hand with judge advocates
to implement good order and discipline
in their unit
the bill really comes down to one thing
is there enough evidence to move this
case forward
we should not put that responsibility on
commanders who
often know both the accused and the
accuser
and do not have legalized training to be
able to make these decisions properly
when it comes to serious crimes that can
lead to
long more than a year sentences that
decision should be made by a legal
expert
that's the change the bill would make
it's tailored it's simple
it's an elegant solution to meet a very
real problem commanders still
have lots of power they have the ability
to enact non-judicial punishment
which allows them to set the tone for
their troops and maintain good order and
discipline
they will still have the ability to put
people on restrictive
on restriction and in confinement they
still have the
issue the ability to issue protective
orders
these are the basic tools that
commanders rely on to implement good
order and discipline not
general court martial and if a serious
crime
is not preferred and then referred
by the jag convening authority it goes
right back to the commander
who can choose to do several things he
could do nothing
he can carry out non-judicial punishment
or administrative separation
he could pursue summary or special court
martial
however this change displayed its
simplicity and despite being a very
small change will create a seismic shift
in how the military justice system is
perceived
by both service members who have been
subjected to sexual assault
and by black and brown service members
who have been subjected to bias
we need a professionalized military
justice system
so that everyone from survivors to
defendants
rights can have more trust in
the current process a process that is
based on
evidence and legal facts and that cases
will be decided impartially
that's the system our service members
deserve and
is the system that we create by the
military justice improvement and
increasing prevention act
we've tried every small ball effort you
can imagine
mr president you've been in on that
committee for years you've watched us
pass
every type of reform that the dod
is okay with this is the one
they have fought tooth and nail to
prevent
implementation and even today our
chairman
wants to narrow it down reduce it to a
very small size
one crime one crime only well let's just
look at the facts
the vanessa guillen case was a murder
case
under the chairman's own analysis he
would not have allowed that case to go
forward through the review of a special
trained
military prosecutor in fact her case may
never have seen the light of day
that's a problem so we need to treat all
serious crimes
the same we've compromised on this bill
we've carved out
all the serious crimes that are military
in nature
going awol not following a direct
command
anything that the commander would have a
special purview over
but we draw a bright line at the rest of
those serious crimes
and that's a good solution it's what our
allies have already done
uk israel canada germany
netherlands australia and they saw no
diminution in command control
we need to build the military justice
system
that is worthy of the sacrifices that
the men
and women of armed services make every
day i would now
like to yield the floor to the senator
from iowa
senator gillibrand mr president the
senator from iowa
i think we just heard the
senator from new york speak very
strongly about the need for this
legislation
she said 12 times she's come to the
senate floor to ask for uc
on this bill so we all ought to know
not only on this bill but a lot of
things the senator from new york's
involved in
she's not going to give up and eight
years on this bill
proves that her persistence
we need to get this done and i would
think
that a a bill that has 66 co-sponsors
and the demonstrate form is such that
the people opposing this would be
embarrassed
particularly with the 66 co-sponsors
so i thank senator gillibrand for her
persistence i've been glad to be with
her on this subject i haven't worked on
it as hard as she has but i believe in
everything she has said
and this bill should pass in the last 15
years there's been virtually no progress
in reducing the level of sexual assault
in the military
far too many service men and women
have experienced sexual assault and we
don't even know the full extent
of the problem because people are afraid
to report these because of retribution
that happens as a result
of the report of those who do report
64 percent experience retaliation
but this goes beyond sexual assault this
legislation
professionalizes the military justice
system
and would improve trust and transparency
in the ability of the military to handle
all serious crimes the policy
of moving the decision to prosecute out
of the chain of command
has been recommended by military justice
experts
this bill has been considered by the
armed services committee for eight years
in a row and that's why
time has come now to make sure that this
bill
does not get buried once again in that
committee
or as she suggested very narrowly
uh narrowed they've had
the committee has had more than enough
time to review the legislation
and propose alternatives we've even
heard from the department of defense
that they can solve this problem and yet
it keeps getting worse
this bill with so many co-sponsors
deserves the support
and shouldn't have to wait any longer to
get past it's time for the legislation
to finally move forward
and i urge my colleagues to join
the joint in this effort to get this
done the easiest way
possible and that would be by uc i yield
the floor
the clerk will call the roll miss
baldwin
mr president the senator from south
carolina uh
i'm asked to be recognized for ten
minutes the uh sentence in a quorum call
uh ask if the quorum call be uh
initiated
without objection thank you uh
i have been listening uh today and a few
other days i think about senator
gildebrand's efforts to bring up
what i think is a major reform of the
military justice system to the point
where you won't recognize it as it is
today and i hope you understand what
you're being asked to do here
so senator reid who's the chairman of
the committee has been objecting
and before i got here i was a military
lawyer
and active duty in the reserves for
about 33 years as prosecutor defense
attorney and judge
and what i'd like to challenge the body
to do
is find me cases where the judge
advocate has recommended prosecution
in a sexual assault case in the last
eight years
and the commander refused to go forward
i was in the military jack corps for 33
years i
can only remember one time where that
was even an issue
and previous efforts to reform the
system
works like the following if the jag
recommends a
prosecution in a sexual assault case as
defined
in the last piece of legislation and
they refuse to go forward
is taken to the commander's commander so
what problem are we trying to solve here
what we're doing in this bill is
relieving the chain of command
when it comes to military justice
if the commander no longer is concerned
about sexual assaults in the barracks
we've made a huge mistake
the heart and soul of military justice
system is to provide a fair trial to the
accused
take care of victims but give the
commander the tools they need for good
order and discipline
so the idea of taking the commander out
of the chain of the command
when it comes to
terrible things like sexual assault i
think is a bad idea
because it's the commander's job to make
sure that unit works well
and having a bunch of professional
prosecutors
make the decision without the commander
being involved is basically relieving
the commander
of what's best for that unit overall
sexual assault is a problem in the
military's problem civilian world is
problem
all over the place but the military
justice system
is designed to bring about good order
and discipline
and i can only say that the day that the
commander is taken out of the
responsibility for what happens in that
unit
is a bad day for good order and
discipline and i think a bad day for
that unit
again the legal advice given to
commanders
in cases like we're talking about
is almost universally followed there's
probably been more occasions where the
commander will take a
iffy case to court just to make a point
cases that would never probably get off
first base
uh in the civilian world but
the people pushing this bill always talk
about results in court martials
i think the worst thing the united
states senate could do
is create an impression that a not
guilty verdict
is unacceptable in the military
sometimes a not guilty verdict is the
right answer
to the situation presented to the court
so i'm beginning to doubt whether or not
you can get a fair trial in the military
if you're accused of one of these crimes
when politicians attack results in the
system
we're sending a pretty clear signal if
you're on a court
martial panel member that we're going to
be grading your homework here in the
senate
because there seems to be a bias that
the only outcome
must be a guilty verdict truth of matter
is a lot of women
go to their grave having been assaulted
and never report
the event to anybody and we need to make
it easier for victims to come forward
but on occasion people are accused of
things they didn't do
i've been involved in many of these
cases
and on occasions you'll find out that
the accusation doesn't hold
water not sufficient
to be anywhere near beyond a reasonable
doubt
and sometimes people say things are just
flat not true
so what i worry about mr president
is in our effort to reform the system
just
to to create to solve a problem that
really doesn't exist
commanders ignoring the jags and not
prosecuting people
because they like them or they have
favoritism that's not a problem
if you want to talk about reforming the
military justice system fine
let's don't stand here in the united
states senate and say
that commanders in the military
routinely turn down
legal advice to prosecute they don't
that's just not true
in the military in a general court
marshal
you need three fourths to convict if
we're going to go down this track
of talking about what an acceptable
outcome should be
then i'm going to start introducing
legislation to change
the requirement of the verdict to be
unanimous
i was a prosecutor for four and a half
years
and a defense attorney for two i
understand
sort of the military courtroom
environment and the
panel members the members of the jury
are commissioned officers or you can
request non-commissions officers
the the accused has that right up to a
certain percentage of the panel
and these panels are constructed not
like a civilian court
they're constructed to make sure that
the jury
usually comes from the the officer corps
and people with the responsibility for
that base
are picked to serve on these juries to
make sure that
the base is being well run people
receive
justice who have been violated
and those accused of trial of a crime
have a
fair trial the worst thing can happen is
when a commander seems to have favorites
and the people he likes get away with
almost anything and the people the
commander doesn't like
well they look for reasons to come down
hard on them
so when i was a young jack i'd go talk
to commanders and first sergeants
the worst thing you do to unit is play
favorites
call them as you see them you need to
show up in the middle of the night
as a commander and first sergeant in the
barracks when they
least think you're going to come just
let
people know you're watching them because
most enlisted people are
18 to 22 year old first time
away from home so we've made some
strides that i think are good
we provide victims of sexual assault in
the military with their own individual
counsel
most people don't get that in the
civilian world we're trying to train
prosecutors how to handle these cases i
like that
but if we're going to start creating a
presumption here
contrary to being innocent that there's
only one right
answer then we need to start training a
bunch of defense attorneys
and have the specialty there because the
worst thing that can happen
in a military unit is for somebody to be
assaulted
be treated poorly and nothing happens
and second to that is for somebody to be
accused of something
that is seen as not legitimate
and that's why you have trials that's
why you have defense attorneys that's
why you have judges that's why you have
prosecutors
but the thing unique about the military
is this not a jury of your peers
the jury is made up of the officer corps
on that base who has responsibilities
usually
to run the base and you can request it
as a enlisted member
that a part of the panel will be
enlisted
but they're going to be the most senior
ranks on the base
they're not going to be three e3 and
fours they're going to be e8s and e-9s
they're going to be the senior enlisted
corps responsible for good order and
discipline and morale on the base
that's what's unique about the military
justice system
i found as a defense attorney that
people look
long and hard at the government's case
i'll talk later on about some cases i
had where people were accused of
using drugs by
urinalysis and the system was fatally
flawed and
over time the military justice system
got that right
so i just want senator reid to know
that slowing this train down
and getting the members of this body to
understand what we're talking about i
will support him more i should be down
here talking more
like everybody else we're busy so i
promise to come down more to give my
side of what we should be thinking about
in terms of reform
and why what's before us is not reform
it's a radical change to the military
justice system
based on what i think a premise that
doesn't exist
the one thing i want you to know
i don't believe
there are a handful of cases in the army
the air force the marine corps the navy
a year where the commander refuses to go
forward after the jags have recommended
a court martial
in sexual assault cases
and that's what we're all supposed to be
worried about
that the system is biased against
victims
what can we do to make it easier to
report these
situations what can we do to convince
people that the command is not going to
turn on you if you're a victim
these are all legitimate things
but to fire the entire chain of command
based on a premise that i think doesn't
stand water
hold water would be bad and would over
time
undercut the military's ability to
maintain good order and discipline
and to be the effective fighting force
so senator reed
as the chairman of the committee i will
try to do more to help him i respect
senator gildebrand a lot
she's very passionate about this but all
i can say is that passion
and justice has to be measured and we
have to be
making decisions based on facts
not just an outcome that we would like
and when we start talking about cases
where somebody was acquitted
as if that was the wrong result that
scares the hell out of me
with that i'll yield the floor and
notice the absence of a coin
the clerk will call the roll mrs baldwin
mr president the senator from alaska mr
president is the senate in a quorum call
we are i said the quorum call be
initiated
without objection mr president i'm here
on the senate floor
this afternoon to call on president
biden
to withdraw his nomination
to lead the bureau of land management
tracy stone manning
he should withdraw her for the reasons
i'm going to talk about here on the
senate floor but let me
stipulate while i have often
spoken about what i consider far
left extremists
environmentalists who are taking over
many elements of the biden
administration
often in the context of why i voted
against their confirmation i have not
yet called on
haven't in my entire senate career
a nomination to be withdrawn before they
even have gone
through their senate confirmation
hearing before a senate committee
but i'm doing it this afternoon
the reason i've never done this before
mr president
is that's because we have not yet
confronted
someone with tracy stone
manning's past which involves
being a member part of an extreme group
that performed violent acts
as part of their platform for getting
attention
in america violence
a group engaging in overt eco-terrorism
by the way mr president this is becoming
a
bipartisan issue a serious
bipartisan issue as i'm going to talk
about in a little bit more detail
the director of blm from the obama biden
administration
just yesterday
made a statement saying if these
allegations are true which they
are then that he firmly believes
that her nomination should be withdrawn
by the president that's mr bob
abbey so this is a serious issue
and it's a bipartisan issue before i
talk about tracy stone manning's
involvement
with eco-terrorism let me start by
saying that blm
it is is an incredibly important
and very powerful
federal agency particularly as it
relates to my state the great state
of alaska the alaska
blm manages more surface
and sub-surface acres in my state
than any other state in the country by
far
in fact i haven't done the math but i
believe
that they manage more acreage in alaska
than they do the rest of the lower 48
combined
that's how important blm is in my state
let me give you some
of the numbers this includes
over 70 million surface acres
of land and 220
million sub-surface acres
that's the land equivalent to about
one-fifth of the entire
lower 48 states
most states can't even comprehend that
size one-fifth
of the lower 48 of the united states of
america
is the amount of land blm manages just
in the great state of alaska so it's a
huge amount of land
and of course by definition it's a huge
amount of power
that this federal agency has over my
state
and the people i'm honored to represent
and mr president it is imperative
imperative that the director of this
agency
the bureau of land management with so
much power
and so much control over my state
and its future in economic opportunity
for working alaskan families
that the manager of blm for the country
be trustworthy to be honest
to be fair-minded to be beyond reproach
and certainly not to have been involved
in an organization
that perpetuated violence against his
fellow americans
and from what we know about tracy stone
manning
she is none of these things trustworthy
honest and fair-minded
that this administration is full of
people with far-left agendas certainly
isn't surprising
we all know that the national democratic
party is much
further to the left than they were even
four years ago with the obama biden
administration
but mr president what is shocking
beyond surprising is that the president
of the united states
would put forward someone for this
incredibly important position
blm who is not only
far left but from a member of a group
that was an eco-terrorist
organization a group that was
undertaking violence against their
fellow americans
so they can make a point on
environmental issues
in america this is not an exaggeration
tracy stone manning was a member of
earth first
a radical far left group that has
engaged repeatedly
in what is defined as eco-terrorism
but mr president she wasn't just a
member
of earth first she herself is complicit
in putting metal spikes
big thick ones in trees
that we're meant to either threaten to
hurt
or gravely injured injure those
americans
who are harvesting trees who are cutting
down trees
legally we're putting trees in sawmills
legally this was a common technique
tree spiking deployed by such
eco-terrorists
in the late 1980s and early 1990s
earth first called such tactics
quote monkey wrenching
that's kind of cute dangerous could kill
people
monkey wrenching logging crews
and the americans who are legally
harvesting
timber in our country might have called
such tactics terrifying
and certainly called such tactics very
very dangerous
so let me briefly talk about the group
that tracy stone manning was a member of
earth first began in 1980
by disaffected environmentalists who
thought the movement wasn't radical
enough
we thought the movement wasn't getting
enough attention
so they founded a new group that wanted
to get more attention
sometimes by perpetuating violence
among its proposed founding principles
quote
all human decisions should consider
earth first
mankind second i'm quoting now
mankind second okay not sure many u.s
senators would agree with that
and quote the only true test of morality
is whether an action individual social
or political
benefits the earth unquote these are
founding principles of this organization
given these principles it's no mystery
that the group's slogan
is this quote no compromise in defense
of mother earth
mr president in their view no compromise
meant destroying property
putting steel spikes in trees
that could kill someone trying to
harvest a tree
and earth first celebrated and
encouraged
such actions the group even put out a
manual
yes a manual detailing
tree spiking and instructions on how to
do other
sabotage activities cut down power lines
flatten tires burn machinery
of those who are trying to harvest trees
legally
we harvest trees legally in alaska we
have loggers who do that
who are from hard working families
david foreman the founder of earth first
talked about
all of these activities and he said this
is where the eco-tour can have
fun that's a quote
from the founder earth first fun
that's what he called this fun
tell that to those violently hurt by
some of earth first tax tactics
this is how an article in the washington
post from this time
described such an incident of tree
spiking
that severely violently
hurt one of our fellow americans and i'm
going to quote
from this article mr president
quote george alexander
a third generation mill worker
was just starting his shift at the
louisiana
pacific lumber mill in cloverdale
california
when the log that would alter his life
rolled down his conveyor belt toward a
high-speed
saw he was working on by the way madam
president i've seen these saws at alaska
in mills in alaska they are huge this
isn't just some kind of tiny saw
they are gigantic and they spin
at incredibly fast speeds
with huge teeth
they're dangerous even when you're
operating
without tree spikes in the trees
let me continue here's the continuation
of this article from the washington post
it was may 1987.
george alexander was 23 years old
his job was to split logs he was nearly
three feet away
when the log he was working on hit his
saw
and the saw this giant saw
exploded one half of the blade
stuck in the log the other half
hit alexander in the head
again these are giant saws tearing
through his safety helmet
tearing through his face shield his
face was slashed from eye
to chin his teeth were smashed
and his jaw was cut in half
that's what earth first did to this
young american doing his job with a tree
spike
in it i'm continuing with the washington
post
article george alexander had never
even heard of a sabotage tactic
called tree spiking until he
himself had become a victim of
eco-terrorism
washington post word not my word
eco-terrorism
someone who objected to tree cutting had
embedded a huge
steel spike in that log
that violently jammed the saw and
changed george alexander's life
tree spiking that's the washington post
these were the kind of tactics that
tracy stone manning
the biden administration's choice to
lead blm
for america once conspired him
does that disturb you america
every u.s senator on the floor here and
this body
should be very very disturbed and mr
president
and now i'm talking to the president
united states think about this
sir i say respectfully
come on man
this is the most qualified american
citizen
you can find to be the blm director
she was part of a group not just a
radical extreme
environmental group but a radical
extreme
violent environmental group
president biden this should be a red
line that we all agree to
no nominees who conducted violence
against their fellow americans
so what did she do specifically
the bi-demonstrations director of blm
nominated director of elm here's what
she did
in 1989 she did a friend
a fellow earth first
colleague comrade maybe is a better word
she did a friend a comrade fellow
comrade a favor
she wrote word for word a profane
anonymous letter from this member of
earth first
about the 500 pounds of
tree spikes that earth first had
hammered into trees in idaho
by earth first pretty dangerous
pretty violent she rewrote the letter
on a rented typewriter because she later
told a reporter quote
her fingerprints were all over it
so she knew she was obviously involved
in criminal activity
so she didn't just hand write it she
didn't want her fingerprints on it she
typed it
she then sent the letter to the fbi
she kept quiet for what she did for
years that was in 1989
until she came forward in 1993
and received immunity for her part in
this tree spiking
in idaho 500 pounds of spikes
this is a serious operation deadly
could be deadly she received immunity
for
her part in this tree spiking when
prosecutors went after the other members
of earth first
and she testified about it
here's something that should be very
simple for all of us
no matter how young no matter how naive
the director of the bureau of land
management
for the united states of america should
not
and i repeat should not
have ever been involved in ecoterrorism
that is simply unacceptable
and the president united states should
get that and certainly every u.s senator
should get that
working with people who were so radical
on environmental issues
that they thought it was okay to
perpetuate
violence against their fellow american
citizens
come on man president biden
you cannot be serious
now it's not only me who thinks that
this
is an outrage i want to compliment my
senate colleague senator barrasso
who has been doing a great job
fortunately our press has been asleep at
the switch
senator barrasso has been doing a great
job of highlighting
these very issues
but as i said earlier this is now
becoming
a bipartisan issue it's not just me and
senator barrasso
who've been raising this issue
just yesterday bob abbey
who led the blm from 2009
through 2012 under president obama and
vice president biden
said the following quote if the reports
regarding ms stone's miss stone
manning's involvement
with spiking trees are true
then i firmly believe
she should immediately immediately
withdraw her name
from further consideration for the blm
director job unquote let me read that
again
the blm director from the obama biden
administration
just yesterday said the following
if reports are true regarding
ms stone manning's involvement with
spiking trees
are true then i firmly believe
she should immediately withdraw her name
from further consideration for the blm
director job
unquote well guess what the reports
about her involvement with tree spiking
by the eco-terrorist organization earth
first
meant to harm her fellow americans
are true
they're true
madam president there are other issues
that also call into question
ms stone manning's character i'm not
going to get into these
i'll let others focus on them low
interest rate
loans other things
that's in some ways in my view a
distraction
her involvement with an organization
that was focused on eco-terrorism
certainly
disqualifies her
and the president united states should
know this
now i didn't agree with bob abbey on
much when he was the head of blm
under the obama biden administration
but i certainly agree with him
about tracy stone manning
and i believe the president of the
united states should withdraw her name
from further consideration
and if the president doesn't do that
because he gets the pressure from the
extreme left
then i certainly hope
i certainly hope that my colleagues here
in the united states senate
democrats and republicans will
resoundingly
vote to reject this nomination
when it comes to the senate floor
yes we have differences on issues of
resource development
energy for america certainly issues
of jobs and resource development in my
great state the great state of alaska
we have differences there's no doubt
about it
but here's the thing we all know and i
think every
one of us all hundred senators
know and would say publicly that these
differences should be resolved
peacefully
in debates here on the senate floor at
the ballot box
arguing these issues forcefully yes
but not violently
not with violence
so if this nominee comes this floor it
shouldn't be even a close vote
it should be a hundred to zero rejecting
her
and to my democratic colleagues i hope
you join me
like mr bob abbey and saying mr
president guess what
you screwed up here withdraw her
but if he won't do that
i hope every u.s senator
votes against this we cannot
condone endorse or vote somebody
who's been part of a eco-terrorist
radical extreme
violent organization
and my colleagues america will be
watching
if you vote for her you got to go home
and explain that vote
to your fellow americans as i mentioned
it's one thing for this administration
about to put forward far
left extreme environmental nominees
it is quite another to put forward
a far left extreme violent
environmental nominee and that's what
she is
so the president united states
respectfully sir
you need to withdraw this nomination
and to my colleagues on the senate floor
here respectfully to all of you
the president doesn't take this common
sense action
we need to decisively
reject this nominee when it comes to the
floor of the united states senate
i yield the floor
i ask unanimous consent the senate
proceed to legislative session
and be in a period of morning business
with senators permitted to speak therein
for up to ten minutes each
without objection and madam president
i ask unanimous consent that when the
senate completes its business today
it adjourn until 10 a.m tuesday june 22
that following the prayer and pledge the
morning hour be deemed expired
the journal of proceedings be approved
to date the time for the two leaders be
reserved for their use later in the day
and morning business be closed
further upon conclusion of morning
business the senate proceed to executive
session
to resume consideration of the fund's
own nomination post-cloture
that post-closure debate time expired 11
45
further that the senate recess following
the cloture vote on the yahuwah
nomination until 2 15
to allow for the weekly caucus meetings
that if cloture is invoked on the ahuja
nomination
all post-cloture time expires at 2 30 pm
follow further following the disposition
of the huja
nomination the senate proceed to
legislative session and resume
consideration of the motion to proceed
to
s 2093 with time until 5 30 p.m equally
divided between the two leaders or the
designees
that the cloture motion on the cloture
motion on the motion to proceed
to s2932093 ripen at 5
30. and finally that if any of the
nominations are confirmed the motions to
consider
be considered reconsidered be considered
made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
without objection
is if there is no further business to
come before the senate i ask is stand
adjourned under the previous order
following the remarks of senator
whitehouse
that objection
senator from rhode island madam
president i want to speak briefly this
evening about
s1 the senate version of h.r one the
democracy reform bill that
we're going to be considering moving to
proceed to
the hope be able to show a unified
democratic caucus
will be a proceeding it's all described
as the
voting rights bill and it's described
that way with
good justification because there are
some very very important protections
that are
built into it to protect the voting
rights of americans which are under
i would say a unique and historic threat
now
um since the perhaps 50s and 60s
when the voting rights act was passed
and some of the levers that were pulled
to keep certain people from voting
had to be stopped and the vote and the
ballot
became available much more broadly and
led to a much more
just society but that is not
the only part of s1 in fact in my view
it's not even the central part of s1
in my view the central part of s1 is
getting
big unlimited anonymous money out of
politics
now the two relate because the big
anonymous money schemers that are up to
no good
in politics are focusing on guess what
voter suppression and in fact
the same individual the same person
who was running the dark money scheme to
control and capture
the supreme court and the circuit courts
has after being somewhat blown up by a
washington post expose
about the 250 million dollars
he was running in dark money through
this court capture scheme
jumped from the court capture scheme and
where did he land
on something rather ironically called
the honest elections
project which immediately went to work
to
file lawsuits and harass election
officials and try to make sure that
voter suppression took place
and if you think that's a coincidence
the honest elections project is actually
a rebrand
of an entity that was called the
judicial education project
basically just a name change to
corporate
hijinks and that judicial education
project is the corporate sibling
of something called the judicial crisis
network and guess what the judicial
crisis network did
for this same guy before he jumped
to voter suppression when he was still
doing court capture judicial crisis
network took the big fat checks
that anonymous donors wrote to pay for
the tv campaigns
the dark money tv campaigns for
against garland and fort gorsuch in the
first appointment
for kavanaugh through all of his
troubles in the second appointment
and then for judge barrett on the eve of
the election
in the third appointment
so you see the same person and the same
organizational connection
between the court capture dark money
scheme and the voter suppression dark
money scheme
it's actually happening in kind of plain
light a day
except that we don't pay enough
attention to the links
so this dark money business getting the
big dark money out of politics
is a big big deal and i wanted to share
how big a deal
it is to americans dark money corruption
polls at the top of all the issues in
the last
poll i shall saw it's the number one
issue and if you ask people
if somebody says that they've dedicated
themselves to fighting corruption is
that going to make you more likely to
vote for them
or more likely to vote for their
opponent all right
among all voters it's 89 to one more
likely to vote for the candidate
dedicated to fighting corruption versus
whoever this one is
who said nah not such a big deal to me
among independent voters who the two
parties always fight for in elections
82 to 2. 82
of independent voters be more likely to
vote somebody
vote for somebody who they see as
dedicated to fighting corruption
and only two would be more likely to
vote for their opponent
so this is a strong public signal that
we are sick of it
and you see it over and over again this
is one poll you can go through poll
after poll after poll
and you see people want the dark money
out of politics they think we're
controlled by big special interests
they think no too much stuff gets done
behind the scenes
and by the way we just got a little
window
into the private conversations about
this to take place between the
koch brothers political apparatus
and our minority leader mitch
mcconnell's political apparatus
and jane mayer wrote about this recently
in the
new yorker and the koch political
apparatus and the mitch mcconnell
political apparatus
were being briefed on this bill on s1
and on these provisions and what they
were told by the pollster is
you know what we're in big trouble
because our conservative voters hate
this damn dark money stuff just as badly
as those liberals do and we've tried
all these different ways to reframe this
to make it look bad
so they might be more against it
none of it worked none of it worked
people want their government cleaned up
they are sick to death the big special
interest money
and they're particularly sick to death
of big special interest money that hides
behind fake
front groups so that it's not exxon
mobil or marathon petroleum that comes
to rhode island and says sheldon
whitehouse is a bomb
you should vote against him no it's some
little phony group with the name like
rhode islanders for peace and puppies
and prosperity
and all they are is a mail drop
somebody's behind him and the voters
know in rhode island there is no rhode
islanders for peace and puppies and
prosperity
they know they're being had and they're
sick of seeing the ads
and it's not fair to them as citizens to
not know what's going on
in the american governmental process
going on right in front of them
and it matters to them it really matters
to them
it's the single most important issue
for 55 of all voters
and among the independent voters we're
trying to attract to our
separate parties 58 of independent
voters
this question of big money corruption
and government not listening to them
the single most important issue
the single most important issue now
make it top three expand the question
what are the top three most important
issues that you care about
eighty-nine percent of all voters have
this in their top three
eighty-eight percent of independent
voters have this in their top three
so let's say you've got a real concern
about health care
or let's say you've got a real concern
about voting rights or let's say you've
got a real
concern about the economy never mind
this is still there in that top three
for pretty much nine out of every 10
americans
and what's the level of concern very
concerned
very concerned is 86 of all voters
and 92 percent of independent voters
about this issue of corruption and money
in politics
how concerned are you 86 of all voters
that vary
92 percent of independent voters said
very
and if you say okay let's again expand
the aperture a little
very concerned or somewhat concerned are
you very concerned or somewhat concerned
about this dark money corruption special
interest pressure in government
98 of all voters
100 of independent voters i don't know
about you all
i've looked at a lot of polling in my
life
seeing a 100 number that is rare
every single independent voter poll
is very or somewhat concerned about
corruption
in our democracy so i can't wait to get
on to s1
and if our republican friends want to
filibuster it
and stop us from moving forward i can't
wait to see them explain to their voters
back home why they made the choice
to come here
and against 89 to 1 for all voters in 82
to 2 for independent voters
take that brave stand for dark money and
more corruption and more special
interest pressure
in our politics good
luck with that i hope at some point we
bring that fight to the floor and we
spend
weeks on it so that as we go into
next year every single american has seen
this play out
they have seen that this issue that they
are
very concerned about that for more than
half of them is the
single most important issue that there
is a party here in the senate
that has determined schemers
the special interests behind the dark
money corruption
good luck taking that to the voters in
november
so to those who are listening and who
are thinking you know
i don't think see how we get around a
filibuster here i i love s1 this is a
really important bill
we've got to get there we hope that the
democrats can unite on this but even
then it's only fifty to one or
fifty one to one if the vice president
is allowed to vote
and that's not sixty so there's a
filibuster
my answer is give it effort and give it
time
because once americans everybody from a
tea partier to a bernie bro
gets wind of which party in here is the
party of special interest dark money
who wants to protect that
like i said single most important issue
people go into the voting booth and they
tend to remember the single most
important issue the issue that they're
very
concerned about 86 percent of all voters
so i hope we find a good way forward i
think it's important for our democracy
that the
rottenness of all this come to an end i
don't want to see more of these
academic studies that show that congress
listens to big special interests
provably statistically
and congress doesn't listen to regular
voters provably statistically
because of this kind of dark money
pressure we've got to get beyond that
we've got a country out there to put
back on its feet not only economically
but terms being able to hold our own
heads high
about having an honest government that
is an example to the rest of the world
thank you madam president and i yield
the floor
under the previous order the senate
stands adjourned until 10 am tomorrow
you